there are a lot of zone control valves
to choose from here at sprinkler
warehouse this video will help you
understand the things you need to
consider when selecting a valve what's
the difference between inline valves and
any siphon valves and how do you know
which ones to use any siphon valves are
so named because each valve has an anti
siphon device built into it to prevent
the backflow siphon inch of possibly
contaminated sprinkler water from
getting into your drinking water they
must be installed above ground to work
correctly and they need to be protected
from freezing weather
they are typically installed as part of
a front yard and backyard manifold this
makes the valves very easy to find and
service when needed but does require
using more pipe in your overall
sprinkler system design inline control
valves get their name because the valves
are buried underground in line with your
systems pipe usually in the middle of a
sprinkler zone and are protected by a
valve box because the valve is located
below ground and the top of the valve
box is at ground level they are less
susceptible to freezing temperatures
typically using inline control valves
require less pipe because the valves are
located closer to the sprinkler heads
and not in a manifold group like
anti-siphon valve and provides more
equalized water pressure within your
zones and when buried underground in a
valve box the landscaping looks more
natural many customers ask since inline
control valves don't have an anti siphon
protection component in their design why
would you ever want to install them in
your system with inline valves you are
able to protect your entire system by
installing a single backflow protection
valve between the water supply and your
sprinkler system this higher quality
backflow prevention device is testable
and can be certified as working properly
which means you always know that your
drinking water is safe and protected
although you don't need to purchase a
separate mainline backflow device like
you would when using inline valves there
is a drawback associated with using
anti-siphon valve the built-in backflow
prevention mechanism is not testable and
cannot be certified that is working
properly for more information about the
advantages and visit
of using inline or anti-siphon valve in
your sprinkler system watch the
sprinkler system design basics video
located on the video page of our website
also not all municipalities are water
districts allow the installation of
anti-siphon control valves because they
are untestable make sure you check with
your local regulations before purchasing
one from azalea's - rose bushes from
sago palms to karats sprinkler warehouse
has everything for your irrigation needs
and if you have any questions about our
products give us a call or chat with one
of our customer service agents on
sprinkler warehouse.com
they really know their stuff and they'll
get you squared away remember to
subscribe to our youtube channel for
more how to videos and irrigation tips
for sprinkler warehouse I'm Alfred
Castillo your sprinkler warehouse pro
[Music]